lebanon has never really moved on from
its 15-year civil war three decades
later society is as divided and former
warlords are still in politics
a general amnesty has left crimes
unpunished while the families of an
estimated 17 000 people missing are
still waiting for answers
the lack of accountability have deep
rooted causes that were never addressed
at the end of the war people will
continue to find themselves victims of a
corrupt and unjust system until that
system is uprooted entirely
it's a system that suspended the
investigation into one of the biggest
blasts in history caused by a stockpile
of ammonium nitrate at beirut's port
two years on political interference has
ensured no officials have been convicted
for the more than 200 lives lost justice
has yet to be served
among them three-year-old alexandra
we will not get justice in lebanon it's
impossible
giving the history of you know
everything that has happened already
there was a time when tracy najar had
hope but she says the re-election of two
mps charged in connection with the
explosion was a wake-up call
you can't ask for criminals to judge
criminals
the lack of solidarity coming from the
people of lebanon
we are alone we feel alone today
lebanon's political and sectarian fault
lines have been exploited by politicians
in the battle for accountability and not
just with the beirut port blast
and in my own case that's my father's
legacy
trying to circumvent a geopolitical
problem in lebanon you pay an ultimate
price for that
muhammad shatak was among the
politicians who opposed syrian and
iranian influence in lebanon killed in a
wave of assassinations investigations
haven't been credible and culprits were
never caught for his son roni an
independent judiciary and having the
tools to pursue justice won't be enough
it's a security problem that lebanon is
burdened with
not every problem in this country is
ours
some are
and i think those are the steps forward
for reform
but the larger picture i don't think we
have control over that
there has been violence when voices are
raised those in power have made the
choice between peace or justice
jazeera beirut